- [Narrator] What if I told you
some of the best Indian food in LA
is next to this busy highway
at a gas station
inside a convenience store.
This guy certainly likes it.
- Mmm-mm!
- [Narrator] Let's see how
this plate of Indian burritos
ended up near the Dorito aisle.
At The Bombay Frankie Company,
you'll find Hiram and his staff
making Indian food at a gas station.
Hiram, care to explain?
- Okay, the reason why we chose
this particular gas station
is because our family
is actually in the gas station
convenience store business.
We had this space free for quite a while
and we thought well,
what a great launch pad.
Traditionally what you
might find is unhealthy,
non-fresh fare,
and when you're coming across something
that's not only fresh
but is true to the most raw ingredients.
So when we start with that
completely off-the-wall pairing
you're gonna be starting
from a really low point,
so all you can go is high and higher.
And we're trying to just
set the bar really high.
- [Narrator] Since they've
opened, The Bombay Frankie Company
has received both critical
and commercial success.
- Definitely our most
popular item is the Frankie.
In Bombay, sometimes it can
be a rolled up sandwich,
sometimes it can be an enclosed sandwich.
What we try to do is make
it ultimately relatable
to the LA market and make it
really similar to a burrito.
It's one of the best
things you've ever tried.
People say never mix business
with friends or family.
I say don't knock it until you try it.
The key members of The
Bombay Frankie Company
is my sister, Priyanka,
- Please hold.
- Our esteemed chef, Mr. Kamaljit Singh,
and our staff.
Having someone come in for the first time
who's never tried Indian food
and are completely
engulfed by the experience,
they truly realize that
not only is it Indian food
coming from a gas station and
being served in a gas station,
that they would try it elsewhere.
So by preserving traditional ingredients,
traditional preparations,
traditional recipes,
we're staying true to not only ourselves,
but the region of the
food for which we serve,
and we want to make
sure that you're leaving
feeling like you got the true experience.